My ferritin is 32. I was reading that
Body is in survival mode and sacrifices hair and others to keep heart working and blood
Oxygenated. What are your thoughts? I heard total is 110 hebeoglobin within range
Your ferritin of 32 is within considered within normal range and
Would you look at
Ferritin levels you really want to look as if it's elevated now if a person has anemia so their hebeoglobin is low
They're red blood cell code is low. Their ferritin can be low as well, but what are the best?
Clues that you pick up of ferritin is if it's elevated so an elevated ferritin is going to indicate
Whether the person maybe is overdosed on iron because they heard iron is good for you so they're taking iron
But most commonly it's due to inflammation
So if a person's ferritin is elevated the rule of thumb is they cannot take iron you're just causing
a gross inflammation and it can be because of the iron
If your iron is 110 your hebeoglobin is in range
I want to look at everything together as far as your CBC to get you know a better understanding of what's going on so